the 2024 Republican field is about to
get a lot bigger as candidates line up
to take down Joe Biden Tim Scott is
officially throwing his hat in the ring
today after filing paperwork Chris
Christie says he could announce in the
coming days and Mike Pence's allies are
launching a Super PAC but all eyes are
on Ron DeSantis the Florida governor is
expected to officially get into the race
next week and he is giving his biggest
tease yet
he just completed what I would say is
the the boldest and most far-reaching
agenda that we've seen in the modern
history the Republican party if you look
at what we've been able to accomplish
there is something in there for anybody
uh in terms of the the issues that we
tackle at the end of the day what our
country needs to be about is this idea
that it really doesn't matter where you
start from that people have an
opportunity to do big things in this
country and that's been true
historically and we need to make sure
it's true again stay tuned
so
DeSantis also reportedly telling donors
that he is the only Republican who can
beat President Biden but right now in
the polls former president Donald Trump
is the front runner by a big margin and
while the Republican race is buzzing
Democrats are stuck with bumbling Joe
Biden the president has Rock Bottom
approval ratings and voters in his own
party want him to step aside but like
always the media is doing their best to
Hype up how great Joe is
anyone looking at Joe Biden and seeing
what he does in a day I mean I know you
would be exhausted if you had a schedule
and probably would take some days off or
I would they show up at everything they
give their time and I mean it's part of
his kindness it's part of his political
instincts and that's going to be
something that they really want to look
at as the campaign heats up
you know isn't it amazing Katie how
wonderful Joe Biden is I mean how
they're gushing about his energy and uh
his brutal schedule and I think there's
a quote where she says something like he
shows up everywhere but he didn't show
up in Palestine and a whole bunch of
other places he's been M.I.A for the
most part before he went to Japan uh the
Press can't get a hold of him that's a
strategy the abiding campaign used last
time and it seems like they're going to
try and use it this time and lean more
on their campaign and structure and
infrastructure outside of DC to really
get him over the finish line but when it
comes to you know the Republican side
president Trump is about to get a lot
more Challengers Ron DeSantis has been
his number one target he's trying to
prevent him from getting in the race
DeSantis seems like he's going to run on
his record in Florida which has been a
good one president Trump has been
relying heavily on his record as
president which has also been one of
success and it's interesting to see the
media pointing out that Joe Biden has
been so successful when you compare the
approval numbers of job Biden this at
this point as presidency it's lower than
it was for president Trump now when
DeSantis says that he's the only one who
can beat Joe Biden I'm not sure that's
necessarily true I think you know
there's a big difference between
candidates and campaign strategy and you
have to have both and there's the
reality of the electoral map which is
how Republicans going to win in places
that they've lost last time around which
Arizona Pennsylvania president Trump won
Michigan in Wisconsin in 2016 wasn't
able to keep those in his winning column
last time around how do Republicans get
that back Georgia being a state that
generally votes Republican as Republican
Governor unable to hold on to that so
you know candidates matter but the
infrastructure and campaign strategy
matter a whole lot too and we'll see how
these campaigns approach that as well
you know um it Lauren's 49 percent of
Republicans pick Trump while 21 percent
picked DeSantis a real clear politics
has 56-19 so the question is uh if
DeSantis says you know he's one of three
Trump Biden uh and himself I mean where
do the Republicans Go real sanctimonious
right
I'm the only one
you know I When Donald Trump gave him
that name I was wondering where was he
going with that but there's been several
occasions where the Santas has
hit his chest in a way that
scream sanctimony I don't know about you
know strippers and uh I don't know it's
very under he never takes him on
directly he does it from the side uh
look I'll say this
I think the former president is in a
better position today than he was months
ago when you have all these reports
coming out and all these uh allegations
that the media made for years and then
you find out that the man was set up the
entire time I mean you had Jonah
Spielberg whatever his name is that used
to work here at Fox that said
Donald Trump brought all of this on
himself we I may have been wrong about
this one and James Comey in my book at
the time had more credibility uh
credibility I don't think that's going
to fly with American voters and you know
the Democrats are some are right about
something Republicans do shop at Walmart
you know about Walmart Walmart always
has a great deal you get Great Value but
they don't like Great Value in their
candidates they want the real guy and so
I think when people see the Santas it's
Trump light
um and why go like when you can get the
real guy I I think he needs to cool his
chops a little bit you're gonna have to
earn this nomination and ask someone
that travels all around the country
there is not a bigger crowd than for
Donald Trump there's no question Jessica
you know the black voter is super
important and 92 percent of black voters
back Joe in 2020. now what we've been
seeing recently is that Joe Biden is
losing uh minorities he's losing the
black vote how is this going to play out
well Tim Scott you think have for any
advantage to the Republicans well we
talked about this a little bit earlier
um in the week The Washington Post poll
which had the most kind of dire
implications for Joe Biden's minority
support appears to be an outlier there
have been several polls that have come
out since then I don't think anyone in
their right mind thinks that there's
going to be a tidal wave of black voters
leaving the Democratic party to go for
Trump but that doesn't mean that he
couldn't pick off another one or two
percent he got 12 percent of the vote in
2020 which is the biggest achievement
for a republican candidate he also gets
more support from Latino voters than
people do and Joe Biden has been softer
with latino voters than Hillary Clinton
was black Mills I include them in
as well as the black voters that will
just stay at home
I gave him credit for that I I do not
think that this is going to turn into a
scenario that the Republicans want where
suddenly things are tilted on their
heads but he does offer it's an uncanny
candidacy right and it has been from the
start in 2016 and so you can get people
who you wouldn't expect to support you
with that kind of
um campaign Ronda Santos is in a tough
spot because he's kind of damned if you
do damned if you don't right he was
gloves off gloves on why aren't you
saying anything then he defends himself
against charges of being a groomer oh
he's too aggressive now he's meatball
Ron he's whatever it is and Donald Trump
is just hard to run against you don't
know where it's coming from that doesn't
mean he's not beatable he was beatable
in 2020 and that is still the strongest
thing in Joe Biden's back pocket that he
was the one who was able to do that but
to this point about you know Donald
Trump is getting stronger I understand
there have been a couple polls out that
show that but if you think long term and
I've heard a number of his supporters on
air saying it's a it's a good thing that
the indictment that works in his favor
last week you know being found libel for
um sexually uh harassing Eugene Carroll
and defamation those aren't good things
I understand it feeds a narrative he's a
fighter right and and they're coming for
him but he's also doing these things and
Bill Barr was on earlier today with
Martha McCallum simply saying that he
doesn't believe in terms of the
documents case that it was an accident
it seems like there was some
coordination for that we'll hear what
Jack Smith has to say
um
I have to finish up okay that's where it
is all right then you know what Joey the
the idea that Trump was beatable in 2020
what what Joe Biden had was a hide in
the basement uh presidential campaign he
also had covet saying I'm going to be
the sensitive you know empathic one and
we've since found out that's not the
case you know 73 million Americans are
mocked degenerates basically uh how does
it play out if it were the two of them
this 2024. anybody is beatable when 48
percent of the country wouldn't vote for
you if their life depended on it and
that's kind of the polarization that we
have now yeah there's no Democrat or a
liberal that would vote for Donald Trump
any more than they would vote for Ron
DeSantis I don't think but what we have
now are Joe Biden's presidency the years
of his presidency what we have now is a
border crisis that everyone watched the
administration take years to call a
crisis we have the draw down in
Afghanistan that turned into to death
unnecessarily we have what's happening
in Ukraine and could it have been
prevented and what are we going to do
about it and where are we with it it
just keeps going that's before you get
to domestic policies the price of eggs
the price of energy the energy policy
things that people that aren't in their
core already partisan about are asking
themselves how does this affect me so if
there is four percent or ten percent of
the country that is undecided you have
to believe that the issues favor Donald
Trump so what Jessica's talking about is
is the character of Donald Trump in such
a gutter right now that those people
won't swing for him on issues and I just
don't think that's the case because we
see what Joe Biden a host of issues in
his own he may not be getting found
guilty for libel but everyone knows that
the hunter Biden issue doesn't just
belong to Hunter Biden everyone knows
he's been in politics for 50 years judge
just one more point on the polling that
recently came out Reuters did a poll and
it was interesting to see that 64
percent of Democrats want to vote for a
candidate that is tougher on the border
and you see none of that coming from Joe
Biden at this point in have every
Republican talking about that now
changing or Democrats vote is a big ask
and a big lift but it's interesting to
see that they're interested in that
topic which this Administration has gone
very far left
is a primary
yeah a lot of people agree with you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else